we've been hearing for a while about the
construction of a very elaborate
nbc store downstairs they've been
planning this thing for years
plywood over the windows it was like you
know it was like some
secret thing was going on right and
apparently recently this thing
cost a fortune to build and just about
three weeks ago two weeks ago
they take all the plywood off and
there's this big
giant nbc store i don't know if anybody
here checked it out earlier today but
it's
they they have guys with bayonets that
make the audience go through beforehand
right buy something or die
and uh it's filled the nbc store is
filled with all kinds of nbc
paraphernalia from all the shows they
they have some
you know i had heard that they had some
stuff of ours down there that they had
some
merchandise for our show yeah which just
blew me away
so uh i decided i have to go and check
out the brand new
nbc store it's called nbc experience i
went down there the other day and i took
a camera crew and
this is what i saw
[Music]
you sort of run things here at the nbc
experience yes okay
okay one of the people that runs things
okay this is where some of the conan
o'brien merchandise is
isn't this nice this is a late night
with conan o'brien uh sweatshirt
and um i've never stood like that in my
life i'm just telling you right now
look what's right here journey back to
ireland
why don't you just have a big potato
display here while you're at it
you assume that anyone who likes the
show
look at this a late night with conan
o'brien memo pad
in case you want to write something down
while you're watching my show
like this sucks or who hired that idiot
you put it on this where does the money
go when you sell these t-shirts who gets
the money
because i ain't seeing it i'm not
getting any of the old scratcheroo if
you know what i'm saying are you
who's walking away with the money well
all the people who work here
i'll give people homework here it's got
my name on it i should have it
it doesn't rip easily it's a nice shirt
ah look at that he said it didn't rip
that easily that just i didn't even pull
that hard and it just came apart
oh wait a minute no it gives two this is
well made
okay look at that
that's the problem what oh get out of
[Applause]
here
so this is all the jay leno merchandise
right here how is this one selling right
here the jay leno
strap-on chin oh my god
i hope you all have a good time i'll see
what president clinton is up to
i understand that this thing serves as a
drink coaster pretty much
but if you're at a party you know you
can not look like jay leno but also have
a handy place you want to keep your
drink if you know what i mean
well ladies and gentlemen it's no
surprise that the devil works here
it's uh nice having you with us satan or
bl zebub
yeah okay this is the today show egg man
eggman and what do these go for that's
only five dollars
which is a rip-off
but you sell them okay just do me a
favor and go
[Laughter]
perfect i think this is the most
impressive part of the nbc store look at
this
it's a 300 ton ball of pure plutonium
and this is what they use to power stone
phillips
without this he's uh just a lifeless
husk
there is an interactive part of the
store that's kind of cool you can be
interviewed by jay
you can drive the desk with me or you
can do the weather
with al roker and uh i think there's a
guy
using the ride with me right now so
let's
check it out let's back up and get a
closer look
okay
[Music]
sorry about that what the hell are you
doing
hey what's wrong with that guy you busy
tonight
that way
help me too much
nbc crap
weakening me nbc has another interactive
part of the store it's called lie down
with actual
talk show host featuring me and that's
very popular woman come on in
put your arm under my head okay that's
nice
and you've got about 30 seconds left
well we sure had a good time here at the
nbc store but it can't all be fun
i got to go earn a living now i'll be
back
[Music]
so check it out
all right everybody we're going to take
a uh take a little break when we come
back
sarah michelle geller is going to be
[Applause]
here
you